hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll we've
all heard that the earth is getting
warmer that were in the middle of global
climate change and that climate change
is being caused by human beings and
their effects on the globe whether it's
farming or fossil fuel-burning
transportation etc so it's a depressing
prospect because it is very real and
it's going to hurt us in very important
ways but nevertheless there's still room
for bits of optimism maybe we can do
something about it
maybe there is reason for hope that the
human race will actually figure itself
out and get this right before we
completely destroy the planet
today's guest is Ramez naam who is a
professional technologist investor also
a science fiction writer he's the author
of the Nexus trilogy which is a
wonderful set of books I encourage you
to read and it's about a future where we
have brain implants that let us
communicate with the internet wirelessly
something I'm very very interested in
myself but in his professional capacity
he's thinking mostly these days about
our energy future and especially the
future of renewable energy so in today's
podcast we sort of take the optimistic
view on climate change and energy
generally we say is it conceivable that
we will be able to free ourselves from a
dependence on fossil fuels and get to a
point where we can still enjoy the high
energy consumption that drives our
society right now without destroying the
atmosphere or leading to global climate
change
so Ramez is optimistic by Nature and
he's pretty convincing he knows his
stuff he lays out a case that at least
it's possible to be optimistic we might
do terrible things to the planet but
it's not absolutely necessary and of
course at the end of the podcast I do
take a little bit of time to ask about
brain implants and other crazy science
fictiony things so it's a very fun
conversation a little bit of reason for
hope in the midst of this doom and gloom
remember that there is a website for
mindscape preposterous universe calm
slash podcast and on the website you can
find information about going to the
patreon page supporting on patreon if
you want ad free versions of the show
and if you want to monthly ask me
anything episode and with that let's go
[Music]
Rahm is Nam welcome to the mindscape
podcast Sean it's an honor so I asked
you on because I'm fascinated by what
things you've said and done about clean
energy in the future but in looking over
the various things you've written and
spoken about this overwhelming sense of
optimism comes through about
technological progress and the future
and so forth and you're not I've met
more optimistic people even than you but
I would definitely say that your 90th
percentile optimist about the right of
humankind so why don't we help the
audience a little bit place you in some
kind of context because you have this
fun trajectory where you came up as a
computer scientist then you wrote
fiction and now you're proselytizing for
clean energy I'm as dumb and I don't
know what I'm gonna be when I grow up I
I spent 13 years at Microsoft did stuff
with cloud services email search Big
Data machine learning I have written
three science fiction novels about
neuroscience sort of cyberpunk II novels
that people seem to like the Nexxus
trilogy and now I'm a clean-energy walk
I wrote a book about how to save the
planet basically and that led me to
becoming the co-chair for energy and
environment at singularity University so
I project the future of clean energy how
fast the prices are dropping and I do a
lot of speaking about how that gives us
some hope for climate change and since
your message does seem to be mostly
there's reason for optimism I do want to
say I'm sure that this optimism is
driven mostly by fact it's right by
research by hey by things you can back
up but in my experience with humankind
it has also been a strong intrinsic
personality component to whether people
want to look on the sunny side or the
dark side of things so would you say
that your you are in addition to being
driven by the facts and and reality
based that you're an intrinsically
optimistic person I am intrinsically
optimistic and I think it's probably
genetic I think that also optimistic
just because of the numbers about human
history I'm in the max roser Steven
Pinker camp of look at the numbers all
the bad things hung
child mortality disease warfare going
down and good things life expectancy
education etc etc going up so that also
sort of gives me context for my optimism
yeah I do think that I'm basically on
that side in the sense that in many very
quantifiable ways things are getting
better if I want to channel the devil's
advocate point of view here I would say
yes but our capacity for doing great
harm is also increasing so maybe the
trendline is upward but fluctuations
around the trendline
are broadening rather than shrinking so
it's very possible that everything it
gets better and better and better until
we destroy ourselves right whether
through climate or nuclear war or
whatever so are you held strong is your
concern about those kinds of existential
worries I'm a concerned optimist and not
just about the existential worries
inequality worries me and I I believe
that being an optimist doesn't mean you
should be complacent and I think we
should be doing more faster and climate
change for instance I think you know
we're not on pace for a two degrees
Celsius for staying below that now it
used to be that this is usual was six
degrees we've bent that curve and now I
think we're tracking for two and a half
to three degrees but we should do more
two degrees I mean people who are
completely not following the discourse
on climate change maybe two degrees
doesn't sound like a lot but it kind of
is really a lot right it kind of is a
lot yeah it's it would be warmer then
the planet has ever been since humanity
the species and if you think the middle
of the last ice age there's only about
four degrees Celsius colder than it is
now so two degrees is a lot yeah at the
same time it's not a threshold where the
world ends like it's not the case at one
point nine degrees is just hunky-dory
yeah and it's not the case that at two
point one degrees you get you know
Armageddon so I think in addition to
people under estimating how fast we're
going to replace fossil fuels with clean
energy
I think people also underestimate our
adaptability as a species and the many
ways we'll have
to adapt to a warmer planet you know
usually I take as part of my I invite
people who I think have interesting and
important and true things to say and
then I try to mildly disagree with them
because you know this is my job as the
podcast host but maybe we should just
let the optimism flow for this podcast I
will have other people on to talk about
the doom and gloom scenario okay for
climate change one way or the other or
for AI or for whatever so that yeah we
can be optimistic a little bit with you
know a footnote that everyone should
decide for themselves so why should we
be so optimistic what is it about energy
production that makes you happy right
now well the case that we're gonna
switch over more rapidly is that an
economic case which is that the cost of
clean energy solar wind batteries
electric cars has just been in freefall
you know if you look at solar panels
themselves because the price you pay for
a watt solar panel it in 1977 it was 77
bucks and today it's you know in the 20s
of cents 25 cents maybe let's say I got
350 times cost reduction that's insane
again just in just the last decade the
cost of electricity from solar counting
everything the land you need to buy the
labor who deploy the panels the other
hardware that you need and operating at
keeping them clean has dropped by a
factor of 10 and so now we have places
where not only is solar and wind not
only our solar and wind cheaper to build
new solar and wind than to build new
coal or gas but it's cheaper to build
new solar and wind and storage in some
places than it is to keep existing coal
power plants and in some cases existing
natural gas power plants running I'm old
enough to remember when Jimmy Carter put
solar panels on the top of the White
House and as soon as Ronald Reagan got
into office he took them down like just
out of spite as far as I can tell
there's certainly a component of people
who resist I mean maybe it's falling now
because the the obvious miss of climate
change is much more clear now than it
was in the 70s and 80s but there are
definitely people who don't want us to
go in
that direction how much of your optimism
is is based on the reading of what human
beings want to see happen so it's
actually really interesting
it's surveys in America and America's
only country that's even like this show
that climate change is hugely divisive
and that hasn't really changed
I mean younger generations are way more
bought in to the science but it's still
highly highly polarizing so that's not
why we're making progress we are making
progress because clean energy is
universally loved almost not quite
universally but super majorities
everywhere say that Solar is their first
choice for energy source for their
community
wind is their next natural gas is like
20 points down from that and coal is you
know down at the bottom so that I think
informs out of the politics obviously a
lot more gets done in blue states than
red states and a lot more gets done when
Democrats are in charge at a federal
level the new publicans but some
actually got done in 2015 when publicans
had both houses of Congress and even in
2017 you know they could have torn down
a lot of stuff that early and they
really left the clean energy incentives
and policies in place that are way do
you personally have solar power I do I'm
in Seattle which is one of the limited
sunny yeses parts of America but I have
I got a solar installation on my home
last year what was that light was the
process like is it been rewarding all
right it's really easy I mean basically
my bills are just going down I have a
separate bill for the solar the utility
bill has gone down by more than the bill
for the solar even in Seattle certainly
in in summer months I'm in LA we
definitely want to do it what's the only
thing holding us up is that when I'm in
a townhouse with the homeowners
association that plans to completely
redo the roof in two or three years so I
presume that solar panels would get in
the way of that so we're probably gonna
wait for that but I just bought my first
electric car and I can imagine the new
future finally yeah it is coming it's
coming fast
I mean Solar is just growing like
gangbusters and it'll fluctuate a bit
but really it's economics for the most
part people buy the cheapest energy
and so now that solar and wind are
usually the cheapest they have an
increasing ability to win in power
market auctions that we have and now
really it's just introducing market
mechanisms to lots of places so that
they actually do have the chance to go
head-to-head against coal and gas so I
think it is you know unimpeachable that
the cost has fallen is so why has it
fallen let's let's pretend that we
actually think about the technology a
little bit is it it's not just that we
think harder about it and everything
becomes cheaper right I mean there must
be specific technological improvements
that have come into play there is a
magical not magical there's a
philosophical question really then why
it's on because if you look at the
decline in the cost of solar or wind or
batteries they all follow what's called
the learning curve and they have a
learning rate or what's sometimes called
rights law right was a world war two
economists who studied the production of
airplanes and found that every doubling
of manufacturing of the same model
airplane brought down the price by a
fixed percentage by 16 percent 16
percent yeah and solar every doubling of
scale has brought down the price by on
average 30 percent and so why is that
it's mostly not that the panels are
better though that's part of it
it is mostly that the manufacturing
process gets better and people criticize
the solar industry as the solar industry
only reinvests 1% of revenue in R&D but
it's not the stuff on the R&D budget
it's bringing the price down it's
actually factory efficiencies so they
learn how to have a higher labor
productivity how to get more work done
with the same number of people they
install bigger machines that cost more
money but have a lot more output they
automate things that humans used to do
they slice the silicon wafers that turn
into solar panels more thinly there's
less silver per watt of solar there you
know I could go on and on the
temperatures they have to reach in the
ovens to turn silica into silicon wafers
are
or than they used to be they've gotten
more efficient so that's what's really
going on that's driving us and the same
at the whole project level the labor it
takes to deploy solar across you know a
big deployment of many acres has gone
down gotten more efficient the inverters
they use it or in DC electricity in the
AC have gotten cheaper and more
efficient across the board people are
finding economies that are leading to
lower cost
I mean said is kind of fascinating I
actually didn't know that I would have
presumed that it was advancements in the
fundamental technology but you're saying
was getting better at doing what it is
we should have been doing all along
so there is she is getting better too
but more slowly than the cost is
dropping yeah and so how far can we
extrapolate that yeah I always I do have
part of me that shippers whenever people
mention Exponential's because it's a
scientist I know nothing's really
exponential other than the expansion of
the universe it's more like a sigmoid
kind of curve right where we'll look
exponential for a while for leveling off
and the question is always when will it
level off do you do we see endpoint
steady-state new normal for solar costs
so I think in the growth of solar and
how much low we deploy it is gonna be
sigmoid because you know we entered a
phase where solar phase one was all of
history till about 2014-2015 solar had
to be subsidized suddenly around 2015
you had places in the world where a new
solar was in sunny places just cheaper
than new coal in you gas which is
amazing and same with wind and windy
places and then were at the very edge
maybe a year or two away really from the
point where building new solar or a new
gas hopefully useful a new wind is
cheaper than running an existing coal
existing gas and then I think the growth
rate accelerates but then they you do
hit headwinds and you hit that that top
of the sigmoid as more and more of your
electricity of solar and and wind that
are intermittent it gets harder and
harder stuff I deploy more of them you
need to deploy other stuff instead to
shift the load around and so on but
that's different than cost it's not
clear to me if cost real
has an endpoint or not but you know
every it's every doubling brings on the
claws five six percent and every
doubling is physically more stuff so if
you look out about four doubling so
there's only two percent of world
electricity so it's still tiny still
that's infancy any room for yeah four SS
gets to 32% at that point we're talking
about sunny parts of the world really
sunny parts the world having one cent
per kilowatt hour solar and that
compares to like five cents from natural
gas you know five to ten cents from coal
depending on where you are in the world
and that's just like a really really
amazing price that gives you the freedom
to do things like over build your solar
by a factor of two so that even in the
winter months when it's not very sunny
you have enough electricity now I love
the fact you've already mentioned that
at some point it becomes cheaper to
build new solar production than to just
run your existing coal plant I don't
think many people that's it a struct of
a that's what I think of as the third
phase of Landry phase one had to be
subsidized phase two competitive for new
electricity phase three cheaper to build
new solar wind or storage than to keep
existing coal or gas running and that's
what we're on the cusp of right now yes
so we saw it last year the CEO of next
era said that would happen in the early
2020s I think tank called carbon
trackers that had happened in the early
2020s and then in October of last year
this utility and in northern Indiana
called nips Co announced they're like
five-year roadmap they're IRP they're
resource plan and they are currently 65%
coal powered they're in a red state went
for Donald Trump by 19 points and they
said it would save their customers four
billion dollars they're gonna shut down
all that coal and replace it with solar
wind batteries and and flexible demand
so they're saying it's here now at least
when they look at their five-year window
their window out to to 2023 or so yeah
that's pretty good I mean when we say
solar production we were just talking
about solar panels on our roof but
there's also giant solar farms right is
it what is there a proper mixture or is
one obviously dominant over the other
most of it is
anywhere in the world almost most of it
is giant solar farms in the US about 70%
of our solar and that probably does
really have the highest value to the
grid though as we get more suited
storage you know putting a batter in
your townhome as well as solar the value
of solar on the edge of the grid at your
home goes up actually so it's hard to
say exactly generally you know most
models find that centralized solar is
just higher value you can you can deploy
it more cheaply and getting economies of
scale then putting it on lots of
integers but the stuff on their roofs
adds value to when we drive to Vegas
we go past these solar farms right I
forget the names of them but right on
the border of California and Nevada
there are these huge fields of mirrors
shining brightly on to power and I'm not
sure what actually happens inside those
towers do they boil water what what yeah
an older former solar called solar
thermal we're concentrating solar and
yeah they they concentrate the sun's
heat on a small area and heat up usually
water which turns a turbine right or
more recently people are building
projects like that with molten salt
instead of water as the working fluid
okay and then you get twelve hours of
energy storage along with the solar
because the salt just had so much that
momentum it just stays hot for so long
that you can keep turning a turbine
overnight okay we convert the existing
farms to molten salt no so there's
actually not that many concentrating
solar farms in the world what's really
overtaking it is solar PV solar
photovoltaics you know materials mostly
silicon based that convert a photon into
electron effectively and that's similar
to what we'd have on the roof right the
same tack is on your roof that's what is
dominant in large utility scale solar
deployments also and you can as you
should just put it wherever it's
sunniest and put it wherever it's
sunniest and you know if you pick sites
that have the best Sun which your house
may or may not and they use tracker
which people don't on your house so they
can track the Sun keep the the solar PV
focused on the Sun to maximize its
energy production and of course the big
puzzle is where you store the energy
right when you have fossil fuels you can
burn them on demand when you want them
the Sun is going to shine when it wants
to shine and so batteries or something
like that are crucial
I presume we've had similar
technological and cost advantages
improvements with the battery situation
yeah between 2010 and now batteries
lithium ion batteries the kind in your
cell phone your electric car and that we
use on the grid have dropped in cost by
like a factor of nine so that's that's
really surprising actually it's really
shocking to a lot of people who say that
energy storage is still actually really
expensive but there's other battery
chemistry's lithium ions gonna drop in
price another factor of three to five
and that'll actually probably be enough
to get it to where we have really good
cheap grid storage but there's other
battery chemistry's like flow batteries
that are more suitable for the grid and
I think this is the year or maybe next
year we're really start to see
commercialization of those and that's a
step function down in cost over their
lifetime could you explain what a flow
battery is yeah so a lithium ion battery
moves a lithium ion through an
electrolyte from you know a positive
electrode to a negative electrode and
back again a flow battery moves
electrolyte through a membrane and so
the and that either one direction of
flow is producing electricity through
the direction of flow is sucking in
electricity and the thing that's really
nice about that is you can separate in a
true flow battery you can separate the
size of the tank that contains
electrolyte from the the membrane and
the power stack that controls how much
power you can output so if you want to
add more hours these tanks are just like
injection molded plastic and the
electrolytes at least in some battery
chemistry's are super cheap like we're
the one that I'm involved with it's
really just iron and
basically and so you just build a bigger
plastic tank and put in more of this
iron salt solution so you can increase
the hours that you store really really
cheaply and is the future once again I
know I'm just asking who's trapped late
into the future but is it that the power
companies have Jai humongous batteries
or that we all have batteries in our
garage so right now in the US the
battery segment that's growing the most
rapidly is behind the meter but in
commercial buildings not in people's
homes okay
so I think this will be different than
then solar is we'll have maybe half and
half of a lot of solar a lot of
batteries at the solar plant at the wind
farm in a centralized location for the
grid but we also have a lot at the edge
and the reason is that at the edge you
know in in your home in the office
building in the mall it has other
benefits and those benefits are things
like if there's a power outage
it keeps the power up and maybe it does
for the neighborhood we'd also have at
the substation right and keep the whole
neighborhood up it has other benefits
like the electricity lines that run to
your home in your neighborhood they're
probably pretty close to full at 4 p.m.
to 8 p.m. but they're empty at midnight
so we can fill up the battery in your
region at midnight with wind power
ideally or maybe hydro and then drain it
down that's the because it it so you get
additional flexibility by having it's a
lot like an insult or we're at cashing
at the edge of the network it's a lot
like that yeah ok good and and does this
improvement in battery technology extend
to cars as well that's I know that's a
big issue with electric cars right now
is the range well I think it's more
psychological issues than anything else
you look at a Tesla Model 3 there's a
325 mile range version right so I think
we're getting to the point that range
anxiety is more about psychology than
about the vehicles themselves that said
what we're gonna see in electric cars is
the batteries get cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper and that means that in a
couple of years maybe
two years from now maybe three a new
electric car will be the same price or
cheaper than a new electric car with a
200 mile range or more will be the same
price or cheaper than an
internal-combustion car that's it's like
very similar and it'll cost a quarter as
much to keep running the maintenance
cost as a quarter the energy cost per
mile is a quarter so it's just going to
make it more and more of a non brainer
no-brainer people to deploy now
increasing range is harder historically
you know price has come down really fast
and capacity energy density how much
energy you have for unit of weight to
the capacities we could call it it has
gone up more slowly so since 2010 the
price has come down by a factor of 9 the
energy density by weight has gone up by
maybe 60 70 percent that's consistent
with what you said earlier about the
price improvements coming from economies
of scale you're kind of building a
version of the same thing but you're
building it better but the thing you're
building is still limited that's right
it is learning by doing a little
different than economies of scale but
yeah it the manufacturing process gets
better a lot faster Elon Musk says this
thing of look one engineer working to
improve the battery factory is worth 10
engineers working on improving the
battery technology all right but at
least I think you're making a pretty
persuasive case for an optimistic
electric future in the sense that we can
make it using solar we can store it in
batteries locally and elsewhere what
about the wind component here I mean it
always seemed weird to me that wind and
solar which are two utterly different
technologies should be in any way
comparable why are they relatively yeah
the same kind of cost well the night
their Solar is gonna be just cheaper
than wind um but the nice thing about
wind is it's counter cyclical to solar
roughly so the Sun only shines during
the day and if you see Sun at night
check with your doctor when
statistically is faster at night than it
is during the day times the solar peak
almost every continent on Earth
is summer and that's the wind trough
that's when wind is low and conversely
when maximum is really it's spring but
it's quite high in winter as well and
that's when solar is at its bottom so
across at continent-sized which is the
right size for grids you get a real
complementarity and you can actually get
maybe 70% maybe even 80% of electricity
from solar and wind and some smart
software controls of consumption without
any storage if you build really a
content science grid and put the solar
and wind up ideal complementary
locations do you see any future for more
wild speculative ideas like solar
collectors in space that would being the
power down or is that just something
that's not even really necessary it's
not necessary it does have advantages
there's island nations and you know
places like Taiwan or South Korea that
would benefit from something like that
but the launch costs have to drop a
couple more orders of magnitude for that
to really pencil out yeah I didn't think
it would be a near-term thing but I just
wanted you know we're talking only about
electricity there are other things we
need power for also right once we have
solar and wind taking over most of our
electricity are we still burning fossil
fuels at a tremendous rate so David
Roberts was an amazing Rapporteur on the
climate change beat at Fox he says look
the plan is this Electrify everything
and make the electricity all clean so
that's basically what we're trying to do
as a first order approximation and what
you have is you know transportation is
electricity itself is a quarter of
emissions another quarter roughly a
little less than a quarter is transport
the cars and trucks we know how to do
ships and planes are hard there's both
small they're each like two percent of
global emissions right now so we've got
some time we'll figure it out then you
have industry which is we have building
heat is like 6% and we have heat pumps
starting to become viable there's still
more expensive than just burning gas but
there's a future for them and they are
getting cheaper and more efficient and
then you have industry making steel
making cement that goes into buildings
and so there are people are trying off
a lot of things a whole lot of science
and a lot of startups and investments by
people like Bill Gates in startups that
have ways to make steel and cement and
plastics without producing carbon
emissions we may be there goat just
going into why does producing steel
result in carbon emissions so that that
industry part and so steelmaking it's
really there's two separate things in
industry one is in most of these
processes you need a heat source and
just burning natural gas or burning coal
is a cheap way to get heat and
renewables like clean electricity has to
get down to like a cent and a half a
kilowatt hour to compete with that now
there are advantages like you look at
electric arc furnaces which is how we
recycle scrap steel and turn it into a
steel for reuse and they electrified a
long time ago because let them build the
mills much smaller get rid of a lot of
equipment that they no longer needed to
use so there are advantages much funding
anyway that's one half the other half is
what we call process emissions right so
in steel iron ore contains a whole lot
of oxygen and you can't have oxygen in
your steel so you have to have a
reducing agent there takes the oxygen
out and right now you burn coal and it
supplies both the heat and the carbon
atoms that combine with the oxygen and
they turn into co2 and if your steel bed
for the atmosphere yes yeah so people
are playing with using hydrogen as the
reducing agent thyssen krupp that's one
of the world's biggest steel makers has
a project doing that at big scale and
then the hydrogen reacts with the oxygen
in turns into water which is not so
harmful to him hit yeah it's still a lot
more expensive but people are gonna try
to get the costs down well but also well
we think about saving the planet there
are people who focus on individual
virtue right you know conservation and
just using up less fossil fuels there
are others who focus on policy for the
solar and electricity part you you know
you paint a picture which sort of
renders both of those irrelevant it will
be it will happen just because of
economics just cuz it's cheaper right
just as cheaper to use solar but for the
steel it sounds like it even if we can
make it more cleanly it will always cost
more money so what we need to do in
steel and cement and planes and ships is
do what started us off in solar and wind
which was policy actually so you imagine
that these learning curves exist every
doubling of scale brings down the cost
why did anyone deploy solar when it had
to be subsidized well because they put
subsidies in place because they thought
if they did that the industry would get
on its own two feet and bring down the
cost and it did yeah better than anyone
expected so Germany you know one of the
least sunny countries on earth actually
like less sunny than most of Canada for
America Germany really started this
solar revolution by deploying huge
amounts of solar and wind in the 2000s
when it cost more than ten times as much
in a country with the sunlight resources
of Canada but that started the industry
scaling and we're going through many
doublings before we even got to half a
percent of electricity being from solar
we went through many many doublings and
each of those brought the price down so
what we need to do is do that with the
sector's that we don't yet have price
competition for is we have to you know
say we're gonna have a mandate X percent
of the cement maybe in California X
amount to the X percent of cement using
new buildings has to be carbon neutral X
percent of the steel that comes into
California in the form of cars or beams
for buildings has to be carbon neutral
and that will create a market that will
allow the startups that have technology
that can do that to raise funding and do
more R&D that'll get them bought up by
big industrial companies that or they'll
scale themselves it can scale them and
that scaling will start to bring down
the cost as well and then hopefully at
one point some point that cost is below
the cost of the old way we did it and
are these policies being pursued now
I've got a to-do list item - okay
we need to do actually it's been busy
lately so you know gavin newsom if you
listen to this podcast I just told you
what you should do all right and
Facebook and Google if you're you're
building big buildings right now you
should build them with carbon neutral
cement but there are actually efforts in
Europe they're not being driven by
policy quite yet but there's big
investor groups that are pushing these
companies like spice and group to say
it's time to deal with steel but you
guys need to start working on this the
problem is that that bison group doesn't
have customers because their customers
are like we'll take the cheaper stuff so
so there's got to be some policy to
bootstrap the market for this stuff in
the early days and drive it down in cost
yeah I mean I think awareness that coal
and oil burning is bad for the
atmosphere is pretty high but maybe
awareness that steel and cement are also
big drivers is lower it seems like a
low-hanging fruit for policymakers to
really make an improvement yeah and I
think it's also just the case that what
looks like very incremental policy can
do a lot you know California I don't
know what the first renewable portfolio
standard it was in California I think it
was 25% or 20% by a certain year and now
it's under percent right but it's
getting up to 20% that doesn't sound
crazy like if we said 27 cement and
steel coming into California or
Washington or New York has to be clean
that doesn't sound unachievable yeah but
that would be a gigantic a larger market
for carbon free steel or carbon neutral
steel and carbon neutral cement that
exists today and it would help those
industries scale a lot and then we have
the cows belching is a methane right I
mean that's a whole nother the last
quarter is what the IPCC calls
agriculture forestry and land use and
that's you know also a quarter of
emissions probably it's hard to get
really accurate numbers in deforestation
and it really comes down to livestock
mammal livestock and deforestation
primarily and there's some other stuff
like nitrogen fertiliser decomposing on
fields manure from those cows you can
mosey on fields
burps that farts count burps and methane
are about four percent of global
emissions okay they're that they're as
big as planes and ships put together
yeah four percent sound small but it's
big with it's the fraction of all global
emissions yeah bigger than all a VA ssin
and all shipping but really it's cattle
emit the most methane and they're what
we have the most of pigs are a part of
it but it's overwhelming the cattle and
cattle are historically the number-one
drivers of deforestation though I think
palm oil also has a big role to play
right now Malaysia Indonesia
I mean deforestation used to be the big
hot spot was the Amazon and there it
came down a lot so it's rising now under
both scenario in Brazil it's still
nowhere near where it was well we want
to get it down to zero or negative we
want to be planting trees and the amazon
growing the amazon not shrinking it even
a bit but now deforestation has shifted
to Indonesia and Malaysia where a lot of
it is planting palm plantations to
produce palm oil that goes to Asia
Nigeria Sudan like Darfur was partially
caused by deforestation you'd say
countries like that in Africa and their
cattle is actually a fair bit of it
no agriculture overall the fair bit of
that deforestation probably cattle most
thing and the deforestation sounds bad
because forests are good but is it also
just taking away these sinks of co2 and
all the plants is that is that makes I
think and more than that the carbon
that's already in that forest that's in
the trees and plants gets emitted until
here right right
and so um you produce an immediate
emission that's quite large like there
was times there have been times in the
past few years two days anyway where the
fires in Indonesia or Malaysia because
there are people labor like using a you
know saw to chop down a tree is a lot
harder than using fire so in Indonesia
Malaysia also in particular people poor
like poor farmers that have small lots
typically light fires
to try to clear land and the fires gotta
control yeah and there were times in the
past years where those fires were
putting more carbon in the atmosphere on
a given day then all of the economy of
Japan right and and then you have less
of a sink as well so what are we gonna
do about this exactly this is what keeps
me up at night
cows carry me more than cars and just to
put in perspective as I'm sure you know
but maybe most people don't like the
number of cows alive on earth today is
preposterous compared to what it ever
used to be right like 50 million yeah
that's just last night looked it was
just over 1 billion head of cattle all
right which is still a lot we like our
cows I mean there was ever that many
cows we out math more pounds of cow so I
mean we can fantasize about impossible
burgers taking over and synthetic meat
but is that really the best medium term
solution I think things like the
impossible burger and things like
stem-cell meat have a chance I'm not
that bullish on them but I think when
you look at processed meat where you
don't have the original texture I think
they have a chance to go into that so we
get a bull pepperoni before we get
impossible t-bone steaks that's right
yeah or you know stem cell pepperoni
before we get a stem cell t-bone steaks
and so I think there is a real chance
there and really it's primarily beef
that matters right so although there's a
case for like there's a company finless
foods doing impossible tuna basically or
stem cell tuna and they're the cases
conservation of tuna that were over yeah
okay but for a climate perspective it's
not enough so we have to figure out a we
have to protect forests just don't like
the merit has a lot of cattle in it too
but guess what in America and Europe
forests are growing not shrinking why
because we've protected land and because
the land that's privately owned for
logging the loggers all have commitments
to replant faster than they chopped down
that's not the healthiest force not the
most biodiverse for us but it's still a
for us and as it gets older you know
it's been 50 years like there's some
serious matter diversity in those I
think a podcast interview with Joe
Wilson who's a conservationist and he
makes the case that we are an inflection
point in the sigmoid curve of human
population and it's mostly because of
urbanization and we can imagine a new
normal where most people live in cities
and there's still plenty of room even if
there's 12 to 20 billion people on earth
for a lot of nature out there not to
Florida that's right agriculture is the
dominant form of our land use right it
uses a third of the land area the planet
is agriculture a third is sort of
unusable mountains deserts so on and a
third is forests more or less I mean
cities are like human habitations are
like 2 or 3 percent it's not very big so
densification shifting people out of
agriculture economy into an urban
economy that's around you know
industrial stuff or services and taking
away giving them alternate ways to
produce revenue instead of chopping down
forests and then intensification of
Agriculture the yields of Agriculture
how much food you grow per acre in the
US are twice the global average and four
times something what they are in a place
like Bangladesh so as farmers in
Bangladesh get tractors fertilizer
pesticides or GMOs which or they're also
prohibited from getting most more or
less their productivity goes up and that
means that you can then pass laws to
spare the forests protect what's left
while still you know pulling these
people out up out of poverty and
producing enough food to feed yourself
so we've got to do that and we've
probably got to improve the cows somehow
or what we feed them one or the other I
bet synthetic biology can do that right
so right now the rage is additives
there's multiple potential additives
very famously there's a red seaweed that
in very small experiments
cows ate it massively cut their methane
production really um and uh if when a
cow is emitting methane when it's
burping it that's energy leaving it so
the people that have these additives
which are very limited so far there's
one startup I know that has one that's
different what they claim is that if you
feed a cow this stuff no no does it
produce less methane but that energy
methane is a very high-energy molecule
that energy gets turned into more
productivity these are the cow puts on
more mass or produces more milk so
that's what I'm hoping is true I'm not
convinced yet there's not has not been
enough skeptical science done on it but
if that's true it gives us a path to
maybe help farmers in a way that also
helps the planet and if that doesn't
work then I think you're talking about
synthetic biology it's really the cow's
microbiome like that does the work that
makes the methane so maybe we can just
engineer the microbiome and not call it
a GMO cow let's pause for a second to
talk about the great courses Plus this
is one of my favorite things to talk
about because it gives you access to all
sorts of college-level courses taught by
professors from the best universities in
the world Harvard Yale Stanford and so
forth or experts from National
Geographic the Smithsonian and elsewhere
who are vetted to be really good at
explaining their material the great
courses Plus app makes it possible to
learn whichever way works best for you
without the pressure of homework or
grades or anything like that
I taught several courses for the great
courses one of which is Dark Matter dark
energy the dark side of the universe
which will tell you all about the 95% of
the energy in the universe which is not
the particles we've ever seen anywhere
in a laboratory about the different
candidates for dark matter for dark
energy how they affect the universe and
how we know they're there right now
they're giving our listeners here at
mindscape a special limited time offer a
free month of unlimited access to the
entire library to get there go to the
great courses plus.com slash mind scape
that's the great courses plus don't
forget the the or the plus slash
mindscape start learning today it's
always a race right between technology
making messes and technology
trying to clean them up and I don't
think there's a rule of thumb for who
wins in these I think that it does there
are reasons to be optimistic but I look
at them not as reasons that everything
will be okay but that there are things
we can do to make things better yeah
that's right
that's right I think like I said we're
not currently on path for two degrees
Celsius and there are tail risks you
know there are positive feedback loops
that most models say are unlikely to
kick in at three degrees C but they
could are we're talking about things
like melting permafrost and so forth
yeah I mean the permafrost melt gets a
lot of press today relatively speaking
it's still a tiny contribution to
atmospheric methane but you know there's
reason to expect some non-linearity
there and most models again show that
it's still going to be that even if the
much faster than expected pace that is
happening it's still a very small
contributor to atmospheric methane but
you know you don't like to see nonlinear
things headed in the direction you don't
like especially if they're unpredictable
a little bit I mean there's a reason to
be cautious but the your example of the
Bangladeshi farmers is a reminder of how
interconnected all these different
concerns are not just the environment
but the conditions of people around the
world and reminds me before I forget I
want to just mention the weird fact that
some not huge but still to large
fraction of our global energy
consumption is Chinese Bitcoin farms
right but but if you're right that solar
power will eventually be cheaper than
coal then even if they're crazily mining
bitcoins they won't be destroying the
environment in fact they'll be driving
down the cost of solar by scaling it and
putting it through the learning curve so
I actually think that crypto current
like I think that an increase in
electricity demand if you can put your
autistic demand application anywhere on
earth is just good for the planet
because it allows us to scale solar and
wind faster because the least cost and
that drives him down across faster now
the reason people mind between China is
because they're trying to escape Chinese
money controls so it's not necessarily
the case that they're gonna
can't put their project in chili we have
a best friend in the world even in China
in the Far West Soler's like it's
hitting on subsidized prices the first
unsubsidized solar plants are in China
were really built this year and the
whole industry wanted to be unsubsidized
in two years right but all these
interconnections again so I go back to
the Bangladeshi farmer or you know kids
in Somalia or something like that or
being rapidly technologized I don't know
if that's the word but maybe you can
talk a little bit about this so I think
this is an underappreciated thing I mean
there are places in the world that are
still desperately high levels of poverty
but things are changing there pretty
rapidly this is part of your optimist of
up optimism portfolio right you know I
don't believe in the singularity but I
do believe in the sink you arity when
everyone is connected and I think it's
the singularity is here right now
more or less or it's happening as we
speak and that's amazing and the reason
it's happening is very simple a
cellphone is cheaper than a toilet and a
cell phone and a cell tower is cheaper
than a toilet and plumbing and a waste
processing system so you have this leap
frogging happening where people you know
quickly and in India and sub-saharan
Africa are you know getting smart phones
getting access to the internet getting
cameras and apps and music and advice
whatever it is they do they might not
even be very literate right they're
getting that even though they don't have
an improved water source or plumbing
system that we would recognize as modern
and that's fascinating and then what the
hope is this the hope is that device in
the u.s. we say the phone is the third
screen right screen one it's a TV screen
two is a laptop screen three is the
phone it's the first phone for most of
the planet it's the first screen what's
the plant so that becomes the platform
for education that becomes the platform
for transparency and taking a picture of
a corrupt official in your area that
becomes the platform for knowing market
prices instead of having to walk to
market and see what's the price for your
crop today you can check on the internet
and see if you sell or not it's the
platform for you know Financial
Inclusion all of it whether for testing
you know collateral guessing actually I
was just talking to somebody like
somebody that's a software guy wants to
do something to improve climate and
agriculture I said make an app that
tells farmers in Africa when to plant
their stuff like that doesn't sound that
hard I'm sure it's really hard you're a
software guy here's what you can do so
that changes a lot and it's happening
like we're in the five year window now
like across Africa I think smartphone
penetration is maybe like I mean cell
phone penetration it's in the high 80s
to 90s among adults smartphone
penetration is like summerween fifteen
to twenty percent except South Africa
where it's like thirty five percent
let's say and it's gonna like race in
the next three four or five years it's
going to get to smartphones being
ubiquitous in sub-saharan Africa yeah
and then what happens
I don't know then everybody has mobile
money that solves a lot of the problems
for how can you pay for a solar on your
roof everybody has an educational
platform and then does that produce more
economic gains as well as people start
to be able to earn a living in different
ways I hope so and I think that might
ultimately be one of the greatest
poverty reducing things on planet Earth
well I was going to ask if you have
smart phones but not toilets do we have
any data on how much that can really
help you get ahead but maybe the answer
is no because it's just happening too
quickly we haven't seen it yet it's hard
to get the data I mean we have case
studies of how it affects you know
farmers incomes go up when they have
smartphones because they have access to
the market we do know that so
having mobile money of some sort allows
you is the key to getting solar on your
roof of your home in Africa and there
because it's too expensive to send
somebody around every place with cash
but we have mobile money that the solar
panels are literally like software
controlled if you haven't paid their
pay-as-you-go you've been paid they shut
down so you're motivated to play and the
mobile money in some places that telcos
or banks are holding it back but once of
it is a smart phone they can't hold it
back looking an app
so that facilitates people getting solar
on their roofs much more easily and that
creates lighting and lighting there are
conflicting studies but there's at least
a good chunk that show that it leads to
better educational outcomes because the
kids can study at home and it leads to
more family income because they can have
a little small business at home where
the the wife is doing some clothes
mending the the dad is doing some
woodworking something that allow it
allows it to be industrious at hours
they can't be industrious and it saves
them money like in almost all of these
countries if you have mobile money solar
on your roof is actually cheaper than
kerosene and cleaner and safer so that
starts to look like you know a domino
effect that leads to some income growth
and economic growth ya know that it
definitely sounds very exciting and
Africa of course has struggled for
generations now and but it sounds from
the picture you're painting that the
next few years are going to be a
whirlwind of transformation there's this
something where the governments in
Africa are encouraging it or at least
not trying to stop it it varies from
country to country I might say I mean
Kenya did some very smart things and you
see Kenya are really thriving Nigeria is
also I mean Nigeria's most populous
country in Africa and like the fifth
most populous country in the world maybe
four is even fifth I think but Nigeria's
economy is really based on a resource
extraction and so that's that's probably
less long-term sustainable so you just
see different things happening but
places like Rwanda Ethiopia East Africa
Uganda East Africa in general I think
you see a lot of economic growth based
on agricultural productivity based on
light industrial work that sort of thing
and is it something that suggests
strategies for well-meaning Western
governments or individuals charities to
help things along yeah I mean I you want
you don't want to just give people stuff
right you want to bootstrap industries
and you know the aid literature is
beyond me there's deep debates in the
aid literature
for any literature of what works but we
know that just handing out money or just
handing out food hangout money it's
better handing out food in an emergency
for instance is terrible because it
suppresses the local prices of food the
farmers can't make any money it drives
the farmers out of business right so you
don't want to replace what's there you
want to provide seed capital and advice
for people to be able to build
businesses on the ground that can keep
operating and you want to mention that
in the aftermath of a hurricane or an
earthquake bringing food is good but
it's not the long-term thing just
because a region is in poverty you want
to build some infrastructure there give
them better seeds instead of giving them
a food yeah you know teach the farmers
better agricultural techniques build
them a fertilizer factory maybe that
they that they arts within their means
to maintain yeah but also corruption is
a big inhibitor of growth and the lack
of markets is a big inhibitor of growth
so you want a government that says we're
gonna have a relatively free market I
mean this thing's totally free we have
competition we have you know access to
capital
we don't nationalize companies all the
time because that makes investors very
scared to put money in we pay our debts
we don't over spend too much you can
spend you know debts been some and we're
not corrupt we don't have we pay our
civil servants enough money and that
they can live on it and we hold them to
accountability that they don't get in
the way of people doing stuff the
optimist would say that if everyone can
talk to each other on their smartphones
that might help ferret out corruption
and other you know various ways in which
governments don't perform as efficiently
as they could I don't know if that's an
empirically testable thing either I mean
I think you'd say that in the u.s. it
has not been as big an effect as we
would like but cell phone videos of
police brutality have exposed a form of
corruption in the US and have probably
started some small but some steps
towards reforming that system and so I
do think if somebody has the power to
take a picture of a corrupt
getting a bribe or to walk in and
surface ly record that somebody says no
you can't have this permit unless you
pay me a bribe I think that's only good
how much good it is I don't know and if
cellphones are this transformative in
lesser developed regions of the world
what's the analogous technology that
will be disruptive and transformative in
the developed regions I know that you've
thought about human augmentation and
brain-computer interfaces quite a bit I
think it's also self conscious well you
know my novels imagine tech that's in
your brain that can transmit it
wirelessly and people are really working
on that Elon Musk with neural link Brian
Johnson with kernel
Mary Jepsen with open water people are
really working on next-generation brain
pure interfaces but it will be slow I
think the the layer between or the step
between smartphones and directly in your
brain is probably some combination of
augmented reality and speech and natural
language so at some point it's not
really that soon but at some point maybe
it is 10 15 20 years away walking around
with a pair of glasses that show you
relevant data don't spammy oh and being
able to speak and have your system
basically alexa with you at all times
but way better and being able to say
like hey you know what's that over there
or check this out oh hey oh shoot i
didn't pick my seat for my flight
tomorrow make sure I get an aisle or
remind me what time is my daughter's
recital like I think that's the the
human augmentation is when wherever you
are then you can talk to and can talk
back to you allow her but also show you
some visual stuff and who knows maybe
it's just your cell phone and speech and
it doesn't involve augmented reality but
it's pretty cool if the thing can also
see what's around you and show you
visual information yeah I mean my
computer does a pretty good job of
reminding me of upcoming things podcast
recordings and so forth but it's also
you know my computer in particular like
some people's it's a little bit too open
to the world it's too easy for the rest
of the world to but in some time so I
think that we haven't yet
figured all of that out and yeah if it
were directly into my brain obviously
that would be even more avenues for
abuse would open up I get to have some
fun with that in the novel yeah exactly
anything that you're gonna hack you
anything connected can be hacked
fundamentally well so the Google glass
got a lot of abuse but it always I
always thought the abuse was a little
bit misplaced I mean the Apple Newton
got a lot of abuse when it came out
right I was a proto BlackBerry
smartphone kind of thing which has now
changed the world like we need some
stumbling first steps to get where we
want to go and the idea of a wearable
somehow that helps you interface with
the world in a smarter way I get why
people are afraid of it or skeptical but
the potential seems pretty big to me I
think it's gonna happen yeah I think
it's really quite interesting actually
and it seems to me that's gonna happen
as well have you did you try ever Google
glass or anything like that I think I
put one on at a conference or something
it did you know what I want is when it
can actually you know wearing glasses
right now when the text or the
animations whatever can actually appear
on my glasses for me to see or be
projected onto my retina I don't want to
have to look up in the corner I wanted
to like you know highlight the thing I
want to look at a thing and it do eye
tracking and know what I'll just I'm
focused on and say what's that over
there you know that sort of thing I want
to look at somebody's face and know that
it knows where I'm looking and have it
present the information right over there
head of yours their name last time you
talked the kid you know I'm just really
bad I'm very bad at names I'm terrible
at names I had a dream last night of
sitting next to someone who I know very
well and I didn't know their name but
obviously privacy and and things like
that worries right are you how worried
are you about such things if if you're
wearing glasses that can literally face
recognized anyone whether you've met
them before or not yeah I'm stead it's
not an unalloyed good it's not an allied
good and you know I'm not all the way to
David Brin who says look privacy is dead
we're gonna have a surreal
society no matter what it's just who
controls it the people or you know
powerful shadowy figures I'm not all the
way there I don't think privacy is dead
I think we'll negotiate a new social
contract and I think it'll be messy I
think you'll have places where devices
like that can't operate or you know
can't record at any rate and wearing a
device that is hacked to be able to
ignore those signals will be considered
very socially faux pas at a minimum and
maybe worse than that I mean you'll
still be possible but there's a lot of
things that are possible that don't
happen often due to social dimension
it's possible for me to like take my car
which is a two thousand pound missile
and drive it into opposing traffic or
into a crowd yeah and we're so shocked
when that happens because it doesn't
happen very often and so there's a very
strong social convention around that in
a sense that you're gonna you're gonna
suffer if you do that sort of thing so I
think we'll eventually get there on
these privacy issues too but how what
the path has been here to there I don't
know well the obvious worry about that
analogy is that people don't make a lot
of money off of you driving into
opposing traffic whereas people could
make a lot of money out of all sorts of
privacy violations and you know I tend
to be on brin side here I haven't
actually read his opinions about this
but looking at you know young people and
how willing they are to share things
online I wonder if the idea of privacy
won't just become antiquated you know
kind of I don't think young people have
got another day of privacy like young
people very much understand privacy and
there may be more into it than adults
like you know ask a young person and
like about anything about their
relationship to sex and you'll find out
how they feel about privacy they want to
choose who they communicate things to
yeah right and they might be willing to
share more with the world on some topics
or with their friends on some topics but
they very much understand that those
things they don't want to communicate
yeah what they learn over time as a no
longer young person I'm probably being
unfair to the young people because I do
see people over sharing on the internet
but it's probably just a
slice of people right yeah the kids
these days they're on my lawn I wish
they would get off it but is there
anything okay what about the optimistic
side of things I can kind of see my
everyday life where facial recognition
would be useful is there's there's
something big it's always hard to
predict what the killer apps are going
to be when we get better at
communicating directly with our
computers is there something that
becomes much easier right away I mean I
think in a way it amplifies our
collective intelligence and that makes
it capable the you know in history we
have inventions made by individual
famous people but that's probably an
exaggeration at not that's not really
how it happened but now it's less than
less how it really happens I mean you
know this very well right in your field
like it's it's giant teams of people
working with giant instruments that were
designed by giant teams of people that
do the work and so that's collective
intelligence like so we have to
collaborate to do that so if we have
more intuitive ways to share ideas
knowledge questions designs whatever
with each other I think that reduces the
friction and increases the bandwidth
between us and probably allows groups
like that to work more effectively you
know I think like look at slack this is
a bit of a tangent but why do people
love slack well it reduces their email
slack finance drives me crazy
interpretations tell people some people
out there don't actually even know it's
like is so maybe you should tell them
stack is like Internet Relay Chat of 8he
we imagine on the web as a team
collaboration tool but it's a team
collaboration tool where you have your
company or your startup or your group
has a channel and inside of it there's
multiple rooms or multiple channels
inside of your space or whatever and so
you you know their team that's
interested in marketing can go in the
marketing team area and anybody who
joins the marketing team can go there
and unlike email all of the history the
marketing team conversations is right
there and their documents and whatnot
and I might be a dev or I might be on
say
but I might pop over to marketing just
to see what they're talking about they
can lock me out if they want to but they
probably don't so it's a new way to
collaborate that has it's not perfect
there's a lot of advantages over email
and the idea is it reduces friction and
makes people more productive together
right yeah over and above you know the
ability to calculate the tip instantly
right because you have a direct
connection to some locale cue later I
personally wonder and maybe this is
optimistic I'm not sure I think that
once you have people are under
estimating the video capture element
here if I have glasses that are looking
at the world or something built into my
brain that is accessing my visual cortex
and let's just say it records an image
once every five seconds of what I see I
think that totally changes the world not
just in sort of surveillance state ways
but just in memory ways like you know
what did I see at that thing that
happened five years ago I can instantly
pull it up I think that quartz changes
human cognition in an interesting way
yeah all around with that there's
something else that happens I think
these videos tap into human empathy if
you eat a stat about police brutality
it's one thing if you watch some of the
videos you're really there mmm right
yeah and a second thing will increase
increase empathy is automatic real-time
speech translation so if you watch you
know some Iran we have tensions with
today if you watch you know the
statements from Iran or a news briefing
you're like those weird people looking
weird talking funny you know just be
honest yeah right we threaten if you
hear it in real time translated into
English with the speaker's voice it like
those news covers might still seem
threatening but you can find other
Iranian content like what if you like
watched Iranian movies because they
weren't subtitled they weren't even
dubbed they were just like translated in
the int the guy's voice to you what if
you could have an Iranian pen pal that
you like just talked to and just works
instantly I think that might increase
our sense of empathy yeah I'm very much
in favor that I did have a podcast with
Paul bloom the psychologist who is an
anti empathy he thinks that empathy gets
in the way
our rationality I think the opposite I
think that we trick ourselves into being
rational by thinking of things a certain
way and not recognizing you there are
other ways to think or other facts that
matter or other experiences of the world
that have completely shaped our everyday
lives and so I'm gonna optimistically
agree with you that our ability to
experience things as other people in a
more visceral way might help the world
come together a little bit I'm sure
there'll be people are gonna disagree
about that but but being optimistic
today and rational is not the default
state of a human tribal is and empathy
dissolves tribalism or these expands
your sense of who the in-group is and
that's what we have to do with global
problems I think speaking of I took no
hippy here yeah techno hippie but so and
I do want to to wrap up you did write
this science fiction novel trilogy so I
so first tell us tell the audience was
not read the Nexus trilogy which I've
read the first book sorry I didn't get
to the next two yet tell us what it's
about it's an idea heavy work but also a
rollicking yarn as they say I think so
Nexus is a fast-paced techno thriller
set and 2040s we're not that far in the
future 21 years where we've invented a
brain tac you can swallow it you swallow
a vial of metallic fluid it still sold
as a party drug it gets into your brain
at little nano machines across the
blood-brain barrier attached to your
neurons and transmit what your brain is
doing via Wi-Fi and so if you and I both
have it we've both taken it and we're in
close proximity
it creates Cory Doctorow hold it a weak
telepathy we can see actually the eyes
feel as if a person is feeling and so on
and it's a story about freedom versus
control my protagonist is like a young
scientist who then he and his buddies
and friends think this stuff is awesome
and they want to make it a platform and
make it permanent in the brain and build
apps on top of it and like give it to
the world so it's it's sort of cyberpunk
but unlike William Gibson's you or only
the elite had it the question is we
could give this to everybody who gets to
make that choice and there's a cold war
with try
Slone soldiers and maybe an uploaded AI
and lots of explosions and a lot of it
takes place in Thailand at a
neuroscience conference with Buddhist
monks talking about the connection
between Buddhism science and technology
and they also like Nexus yeah I mean
slightly parenthetically but I read it
very close to when I read the windup
girl and I'm like all the great science
fiction is set in Southeast Asia these
days that's just weird hollow loopy I
love the guy he's a friend of mine we
talk at least on on flack actually
pretty often
I love the windup girl also another
amazing novel set in Thailand and yeah
by authors with Egyptian and Italian
last names so I was wondering whether
there's a connection there or not but it
is maybe there's things going on but why
did you write science fiction novels I
mean I'm very tempted to write fiction
myself but it never quite screwed up the
courage / time to do it but you made a
conscious decision is it is it because
this is the best way to work out these
ideas is it this the best way to reach
an audience or is it just it sounded
like fun I read science fiction as the
dominant thing that I read growing up
and I thought it I think science fiction
is the literature of ideas it's the
literature that really has ideas about
the big picture and then frankly I was
writing I wanted to write my book on how
to save the planet called the infinite
resource and my agent didn't like it
you're the reason I have a science
fiction career thank you and so I like
okay I didn't take I'd written a
non-fiction book before about human
augmentation I'd written a chapter about
bringing food interfaces well I'm gonna
take that and make it a novel and I just
did it and along the way then we found a
formulation of the book on energy and
climate and resources that my agent did
like and we sold that book to then I had
two books to write that was of this year
did you find it challenging to write
fiction do you know I mean there's
people there's the relationships the
whole that is a very different genre I
think I got a lot better by doing it I
got a lot of advice most novelists
really keep it close to the heart and
like don't share a lot of what they're
writing they just give it to their
editor maybe call people I had 55 people
read a different dress
of Nexus friends of mine and give me
copious feedback they're just friends
that I said will you read it you know
and I took some advice from David Brent
actually it like first I asked them
where do you put the book down where
were you born
look down please tell me that page
number I'll tighten it but I'll ask them
a whole bunch of other questions and
then I invite them over for like
discussion of like what they liked and
didn't like and I would say my first
draft was a hot mess and not very good
and probably offensive in some ways and
my by the fourth or fifth draft which is
what you read it had gotten a lot better
thanks not just to me but collective
intelligence there you go yeah
old-fashioned collective intelligence
yeah and so aside from the personal
reward of doing it do you think it's
been effective are you happy with how
people responded yeah people love the
book I mean the people who read it like
it found a certain audience right among
people that are in tech and science and
neuroscientists like it which is the
best complement to me so it's awesome
it's been a a nobody ever emails me and
says man your nonfiction or that blog
post about solar economics kept me up to
3:00 a.m. booth yeah but occasionally
somebody will be like man how subtlety
and we hate your novel and that's a
treat and so I do think fiction
narrative is a superpower actually yeah
because human brains did not evolve to
be irrational or you know data weighing
or whatnot Paul bloom is wrong right we
evolved - well sorry fair - Paul he's
not saying that we are rational he's
saying that we should work to maximize
our rationality and Putin gets in the
way
I retract him being gone but we're not
rational and it's not even empathy it's
just narrative right and so if you can
tell a narrative be very responsible
with it because it slides past
rationality and penetrates a deeper
level of the reader or listener and they
can start to believe things and so I do
think that fiction is a very powerful
tool to change opinions Alex Rosenberg
who was another previous guest he's a
philosopher who rails against how
stories can be used to make people
believe things rather than you know
deliberative argument
and he was failing in getting this
message across so he began to write
novels to illustrate his point and
they've been wildly successful so there
you go
do you have future plans for more
fiction you know as soon as we have
finished the energy transition no it's
not gonna be that long that's gonna be a
while
I yes but I don't know when I definitely
have more novels in me to write but the
clean energy thing is sort of
all-encompassing right it's a pretty big
thing yeah but I mean when you write a
novel or when you anticipate writing a
novel do you is it the idea that is
there first and you want to illustrate
it or do you get a plot in your head or
characters and what a you know put them
an interesting situation I get vignettes
and themes there's things I look around
and I'm interested in I'm interested in
in tech unemployment I'm interested in
AI I'm interested in the belief which i
think is totally mistaken that AIS will
be killer hey I want to take over the
world I'm interested in uploading I'm
interested in all the stuff happening
with fake news and interest in the
future of empathy interests an AR and VR
and so I you know there's things that
sort of bubble up in my head and I think
about what could the world look like
what's an interesting world and what's
the conflict going on what's the mystery
or the conflict that pulls you through
yeah lots of novels to be written well
good so I think we've done a pretty good
job of being optimistic mostly or at
least giving people fuel for optimism is
there any parting message you want to
leave that maybe action items like what
can we do to even improve the chances
that the optimistic timeline comes to
pass that's a good question well just
say this like when you read the news
like go look for a stat go look for a
number when you hear about any bad thing
that happened go look for the context of
like the larger number that it's in it
because the news exists to get your
clicks and that that's it is as well I
don't I know that outrage works and so I
love great you know news media but the
real news is science and numbers and so
keep hope because the story that gets
the most revenue for news media is the
most negative story and so [ __ ] you know
go find the ways the world is getting
better and tell people about it
because it'll lift them out of their
malaise and it'll motivate them not make
them complacent yeah my version of that
is that I think that news stories should
be much more filled with rates and
frequencies and fractions of things
rather than just things happening even
in Vox which I really do like in many
ways there was a story about buffet
restaurants and how there was a
salmonella outbreak so I'm like okay
welcome what is the rate of that
compared to Salmonella outbreaks
elsewhere I think that's a little
cognitive improvement that you could
adopt very wide totally all right Ramez
naam thanks so much for be on the
podcast is a very uplifting fun message
dawn thank you so much it's been a blast
[Music]
you
[Music]